donner la mort à lévis merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
quelle a été la réaction
en italie après les excuses de l'union
européenne vous savez que déjà on avait
dit avec beaucoup de rhétorique nom et
ses motos italiennes ou les italiens
nous connaissant très bien la rhétorique
et voilà je pense que bon les excuses
elles sont toujours bien venues
mais ça les change rien ça changera la
question c'est le manque quand le héros
comprennent pas qu'il faut faire les
airs au bond
parce que sinon vraiment l'europe à mon
avis va cesser solidarité surtout sans
colle justement vous vous l'évoquiez à
l'instant les pays du sud de l'union
européenne c'est à dire l'espagne
l'italie et la france ont réclamé une
cette mutualisation de la dette à ce que
vous appelez les corona bon et les pays
du nord l'allemagne les pays bas eux
rejettent cette option est ce qu'on va
être face à de nouvelles tensions au
sein de l'europe selon vous a bien sûr
mais je pense aussi et c'est dommage
mais j'ai je vais dit à la télé vraiment
à l'appeler italienne il y a des mois je
leur ai demandé pourquoi on ne prendrait
pas de mesures de précaution pour
l'épidémie que vous savez à la chine est
apparue au début de mois déjà
maintenant la même situation je pense
soit au nord de l'europe c'est à dire
que c'est pays il ne comprend pas qu'ils
vont se trouver exactement d'un autre
situation
ça va changer vraiment je pense leur
avis sur les coroners bande alors pour
revenir à la situation dans votre pays
l'italie
les nombre de nouvelles hospitalisations
et d'admission en soins intensifs
augmente moins vite
on l'a vu à peine plus d'un pour cent
des hausses mardi soir pour ces deux
indicateurs et l'accroissement du nombre
de décès est aussi moins rapide il se
stabilise sous les 8% depuis trois jours
c'est une lueur d'espoir pour les
italiens voilà la question c'est
exactement ça je pense que la peur c'est
pas de panique c'est mesure pour ses
protégés la paire va nous protéger parce
que si nous avons père nous faisons
c'est qu'on appelle la distance sociale
c'est à dire que nous restons à la
maison et nous faisons pas des choses
qui vont nous mettre en péril alors
maintenant en italie on a vraiment un
gros problème parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui pensent que le ralentissement
de l'épidémie qui s'est vraiment très
paix il faut les dire voilà nous avons
eu presque 700 morts
ça veut dire que il y à l'épidémie vous
savez un milan dans cette période
d'épidémie
on a eu les 76 % en plus des morts par
respect à les chiffres de l'année
dernière dans la même période
alors les risques ici j'espère que ça ça
va terminer vite mais les risques c'est
que on et prendre plus au sérieux le
règle parce que heureusement nous sommes
un pays démocratique et alors on ne peut
pas imposer aux gens de rester à la
maison
mais il faut faire contre sur les
responsabilités de chacun et
malheureusement par exemple il faut les
dire je vous le dis parce que je pense
que en france
il faut savoir ce que c'est parce en
italie parce que malheureusement le son
ep avant à vous pour ces queues qui
concerne la situation
alors justement il se dit que de naples
à palerme de nombreuses italien exclut
comment se tape protesté de leur abandon
est ce que c'est le cas à ce qu'à un
véritable risque de pillage dans la
région comment les autorités gèrent la
situation
voilà en question parce que vous savez
que l'italie a toujours de face
c'est-à-dire la phase européenne
c'est-à-dire lé nord et les centres et
la phase qui si bons qu'ils ne marchent
pas tellement tellement vite tellement
bien vers le futur qui sait le sud et au
ce2 malheureusement nous avons beaucoup
des sikhs et nous appelons lavoro niro
c'est à dire les gens qui travaillent
sans payer les taxes et sans avoir l
encadrement sans avoir commandé ton pour
beau quand vous êtes payés régulièrement
ils ne sont pas employés
on les paye crèche alors ces gens là et
ils ont bu ou totalement partir tous etc
et ils pouvaient gagner parce qu' ils
sont des gens qui font des boulots par
exemple pour les parkings qui barre des
choses au marché ou bien qu'ils font de
petits travaux à la maison qui personne
ne l'appelle plus de l'épée ue et voilà
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
demandent de l'argent pour marché pour
acheter les choses pour manger et les
vrais péril pour nous c'est que cette
situation soit géré et non par les
gouvernements qui scellera du
gouvernement mais malheureusement pour
la mafia qui va profiter des ca pour
s'est réaffirmé comme une organisation
qui s'occupe des gens et ça c'est
certainement le désastre alors pour
conclure il nous reste très peu de temps
mais le déconfinement doit être dans
toutes les têtes à vous l'évoquiez tout
trailer quelle stratégie selon vous va
prendre le gouvernement italien âgé
parce que bon on espère que ça va
ralentir c'est à dire qui on va
rejoindre les piques et alors je pense
que les prochains
décret du gouvernement c'est à dire à la
boîte et des d'avril après pâques sert à
quelque chose qui va réouvrir très
lentement avec tous les processions et
surtout chez nous on se parle de faire
une différence entre les gens qui vont
revenir à leur boulot à travers les rage
c'est à dire que les gens ils vont
retourner au boulot et les
cinquantenaires et après ils vont rester
à la maison peut-être avec les smart
work in je pense que ça ça va être parce
que pour ça mais pas du tout les
théâtres les fêtes les cinémas bow non
seulement les résines parce que pour
nous
vous savez les usines sont très
importants merci beaucoup on tenait là
bon à lévis d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes merci beaucoup et je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste à
la stampa